salut c'est monsieur groupe aujourd'hui
on va parler des dernières rumeurs deux
dernières fuites concernant apple
il y en a pas mal c'est un petit peu le
moment raison de faire un point global
pour voir où on en est par rapport à
apple par rapport aux iphone qui vont
arriver d'ici très peu de temps le dab à
l'hôtel de ville du sinaï où tout cas
partie software s'est fait maintenant on
va passer à la partie hardware mais si
très peu de temps et ça on en passe
apple fait couler beaucoup d'or ça
intéresse énormément de personnes moi le
premier en tant que passionné de
high-tech jeu forcément très curieux
d'aller voir ce qui se passe du côté de
chez apple
mais juste avant de commencer je vous
parlais dans mon plan dans cette qui
s'appelle crans chopper je vous parle de
crosse pas pour plusieurs raisons a
toutefois bien raison pour laquelle vous
en parle c'est une boîte française qui
ma disposition un super outil pour
pouvoir dénicher des produits au
meilleur prix alors s'agit pas d'un
comparateur prix c'est beaucoup plus
pertinent est beaucoup plus intéressant
que ça imaginez vous voulez acheter un
produit vous voulez pas passer des
heures sur tous les comparateurs prix
parce que vous avez vraiment pas envie
de vous embêter vous voulez par contre
le meilleur prix la meilleure offre aux
meilleures conditions et c'est justement
à quatre mains crochues peur et c'est là
qu'une solution est super intéressant
parce qu'au final c'est pas vous qui
allez chercher ce sont d'autres
personnes qui sont complètement
indépendants qui vont chercher pour vous
par exemple
moi j'ai voulu rechercher pour acheter
un iphone 10 gt regarder directement
dans leur top 10 je crois que c'est
plutôt intéressant j'ai voulu comparer
avec ce qu'on pouvait y trouver ailleurs
j'ai pris un lien d'un e-commerçant
lambda sur internet je les collais j'ai
demandé à ce que quelqu'un de la
communauté aille chercher pour moi j'ai
reçu très rapidement un résultat et ça
m'a permis d'avoir une offre vraiment
intéressante
l'intérêt pour vous c'est que vous êtes
quelqu'un qui va chercher pour vous et
que vous trouvez les tarifs les plus
intéressants du marché et ce qui est
intéressant pour chopper si tu as gagné
des points qui a pouvoir convertir en
chèques cadeaux amazon ou alors avoir un
virement ou l'argent centre est pas ça
c'est top
après un partage et de bons plans avec
vous je vais maintenant vous parler des
iphone de 2010 parce que c'est un sujet
qui est vraiment hyper intéressant je
voulais déjà parlé il ya quelques temps
sur les différents iphone on connais un
petit peu les grandes lignes il ya plein
d'autres choses qui sont arrivées je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt pas
mal au niveau calendrier pour faire un
point global essayer de voir ce qu'on va
vraiment avant tout cas ce qu'on devrait
avoir
du point de vue ses iphone pour cette
année il ya eu pas mal de rumeurs fort
couru pour l'arrivée hypothétique d'un
iphone et ce2 on l'attendait au d'abdou
des menus dit si apple s'est vraiment
concentré sur la partie logicielle et
pas du tout de matériel sur cette partie
là pour l'instant défaut des ce2 s'est
pas réellement s'il va sortir est ce
qu'il aurait un nouveau design
s'il garderait le design de l'ancien
iphone bon pour l'instant cette partie
là reste encore un petit peu obscur donc
on va vraiment la mettre de côté et se
concentrer sur les iphone l'évolution du
cap de l'iphone 10 parce que ce qu'on
sait sur l'iphone dit c'est qu'on aura
trois nouveaux iphone cette année deux
iphone oled 1 avec un écran 5,8 pouces
l'autre avec un écran 6,5 pouces et un
iphone un peu moins cher plus abordable
pour vraiment se mettre en frontal avec
la concurrence chinoise qui propose des
produits avec des supers spec et des
tarifs qui sont relativement bas on
aurait donc
un iphone 6,1 pouces lcd vous auriez sur
les deux premiers smartphones 4 gigas 4
gigas de mémoire et sur le modèle lcd 3
giga ça peut effectivement paraître un
peu léger par rapport à ce qu'on
retrouve sur le marché où vous avez dû
vous dit notamment des produits chinois
avec des spécifications techniques avec
6 8 gigas on va se dire que des iphone
avec la marque apple qui est avec
samsung leader du marché
on peut se demander pourquoi juste 3 ou
4 gigas si vous connaissez apple si vous
avez déjà eu des iphone dans les mains
vous savez qu'il fonctionne très bien et
que c'est un prix complètement optimisé
main vous soyez un gamer invétéré et
qu'il vous faut absolument une machine
hyper puissante ou quelqu'un on va aller
sur le réseau fon ou équivalent sinon
professionnel tout le monde avec ces
produits-là voudriez pas être déçu parce
que ce qu'on voit cette année c'est
qu'il ya vraiment plusieurs objectifs
très fort pour apple
le tout premier c'est vraiment qu'apple
s'est fait devancé et pas très longtemps
au niveau de la course photophone on a
vu cette année le samsung galaxy s 9
plus on a vu le p 20 pro de huawei qui
sont des smartphones énorme au niveau de
la photographie et même si l'iphone
issad excellent smartphone à mon sens
c'est quand même fait devancer par ses
deux principaux concurrents
donc apple a vraiment forte à faire son
retour dans la course au niveau des
photophones et proposer un produit on
pense notamment aux produits avec le
plus grand écran qui aura de meilleures
performances pour vraiment aller
chercher un appareil doté d'une
excellente qualité
et justement au niveau de l'appareil
photo il devrait y avoir un appareil
photo complètement optimisé au pouvoir
de la réalité augmentée c'est vraiment
un cheval de bataille qui est très fort
pour apple et pour tim cook qui croit
davantage à la réalité augmentée est peu
assez peu à la réalité virtuelle qui en
faire davantage alors que la réalité
augmentée ou vont davantage au monde et
ouvre davantage au partage donc des
iphone qui devrait être complètement
optimisé une nouvelle puce plus de
performance la puce à 12 qui va faire
son arrivée d'ici très peu de temps avec
la puce aoun a déjà fait un pas en avant
vraiment la dernière avec la réalité
augmentée
là on devrait aller encore plus loin
justement pourquoi le photographier par
les photophones nié une rumeur qui est
très intéressante et qui ferait état sur
une hypothétique iphone probablement pas
en 2018 mais en 2019 d'avoir trois
capteurs photo à l'arrière on peut dire
que c'est la course aux capteurs plus en
a plus les plus hauts et plus
intéressant on passe entre eux mais
rassurez vous avec 20 capteur de chaque
côté mais c'est vrai que pour aller plus
loin en termes de prise de photos en
faible luminosité
pour aller plus loin en réalité
augmentée pour aller plus loin dans la
qualité l'image dans la captation ça
avoir un sens cette année néanmoins on
n'aurait pas la voir on devrait
retrouver sur cet iphone de 6,5 pouces
oled un double capteur photo avec au
milieu un flash led certains d'entre eux
porteront sur internet avec des
documents qui ont fuité parler vraiment
de se rendre compte de ce à quoi
pourrait ressembler cet appareil il aura
sensiblement la même tête que l'iphone
10/02/2010 est d'ailleurs que ce soit ce
modèle en 6 5 pouces ou alors le modèle
en 5,8 pouces nisa par une dimension qui
sera quand même un petit peu plus
grandes sinon ça sera la même chose
d'ailleurs en dimensions sur l'iphone le
plus grand modèle
il devrait mesurer 157,2 pas 77,1 mm
malgré tout il devrait quand même être
plus compact qu'un iphone 8 plus mais
comme je le dis avec un écran beaucoup
plus grand
a contrario l'iphone le moins cher
l'iphone low cost lui qui à l'écran de
6,1 pouces devrait mesurer 147,2 par 71
52 mm est à voir à l'arrière un seul
capteur photo c'est ce qu'on peut voir
sur plusieurs documents qui ont fuité et
notamment sur une coque de constructeurs
clocks auquel on retrouve le dos cet
appareil
ce sont des rumeurs qui semblent se
confirmer par des fuites en tout cas
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que ça
permet vraiment de se rendre compte de
ce que prépare apple et ce qu'ils ont
dans leurs cartons vote pas très
intéressant on devrait retrouver faye
saïdi sur les trois appareils sur le 5 2
8l 6,5 pouces qui sont les deux modèles
les plus haut de gamme à des écrans oled
on aura bien évidemment fait sa vie mais
un fayçal dit nouvelle génération plus
performant plus rapide et de fayçal dit
première génération qui donc sorti
l'année dernière avec l'iphone de 2010 7
équipera cet iphone low cost de 6,1
pouces une question reste en suspens par
rapport à l'intégration d'un capteur
empreintes digitales directement sur
l'écran on voit des brutes constructeurs
qui sont positionnées dessus vivo au pot
est ce qu'apple va aller dessus ou
escapade vraiment rester sur le fixe a
dit à mon avis ils vont vraiment raté
sur fayçal 10 septembre a compliqué
qu'ils fassent doublon des hautes
technologies
pourquoi avoir supprimé en tête chaibi
pour ajouter un tom shayes dit intégré à
l'écran même si c'est une nouvelle
technologie même si elle peut paraître
séduisante ça sera en quelque part des
abeilles saïdi donc ça n'aura que très
peu de sens et notre humeur intéressant
qui fait état de la disparition de tous
les boutons physiques directement sur
cet iphone c'est là que vous auriez un
iphone avec une caméra trop d'aix est
absolument aucun
donc physique aucun bouton de volume
aucun switch à off
aucun bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre absolument rien j'ai du mal à
croire à cette rumeur est ce qu'à terme
on va y arriver peut-être mais dans
l'état actuel des choses ça me semble
quand même relativement compliqué
d'autant plus que dès lors que vous avez
un problème avec votre appareil que vous
êtes devant le réinitialiser vous êtes
dingues redémarrer n'est pas de bouton
pour faire un reset vous risquez
rapidement votre viande était notre
humeur intéressant faisait état du
remplacement du port lightning part de
l'usb type c on m'a posé la question
directement sur twitter et au final j'ai
du mal à y croire et je vais vous dire
pourquoi tout simplement parce que le
port lan hing et le port propriétaire
d'apple apple gagne de l'argent avec le
port light ni vous prenez l'ensemble des
constructeurs comme fabriquer des
accessoires pour apple il paye des
royalties apple pour utiliser le port
lightning c'est le fameux made for
iphone j'imagine mal apple se priver
d'une manne financière et à les rendre
obsolètes tous ces appareils ça n'aurait
globalement assez peu de sens à moins de
proposer à la natte acteurs port
lightning usb type c mais une fois de
plus et à tatort risque de disparaître
on devrait voir sa dé la disparation de
l'adaptateur port jack vers le port
lightning donc apple a vraiment fait un
show aussi là dessus qu'on reste
uniquement vers des casques bluetooth
j'imagine très difficilement cette année
apple nous supprime de parler très
clairement pour une question de business
une question de made for iphone est une
question de port propriétaire
ça me semblerait assez aberrant
peut-être dans plusieurs années mais à
l'heure actuelle j'ai du mal à croire
qu'en est il des noms de l'iphone on a
eu l'iphone iphone 3g 3gs 4 et daniel
vous en passe et des meilleurs pour
arriver jusqu'au 8 8 plus et l'iphone 10
on a vu qu'avec le changement nom
d'iphone 8,8 plus en arrivant à l'iphone
10 mathis et 10 pour les 10 ans de
l'iphone on va pas arriver sur un iphone
9 l'année prochaine et attaquer ensuite
par un iphone 11 ça n'aurait globalement
pas de sens donc c'est très clairement
la fin de la numérotation des iphone
alors qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver par
la suite
a priori il aurait espèce de consensus
autour d'un nom générique comme on peut
retrouver sur les mac d'ailleurs on
retrouve plus avec le mcs un bac 2 bac 3
maximax alors on aurait donc iphone 10
iphone 10 plus pour le grand modèle en
six heures de 5 pouces et iphone pour le
modèle low cost d'ailleurs dites moi ce
que vous en pensez
si vous êtes d'accord avec cette
appellation pour le modèle low cost
aussi les rumeurs sur l'iphone x sxs a
fait extra small c'est païta et hâtifs
j'ai du mal à y croire quant à l'iphone
10 l'appeler l'iphone 10,2 voilà je
trouve que c'est un petit peu redondant
coller une numérotation pardessus
numérotation avec très peu de temps sans
réalité à noter sur l'iphone 6 2 5
pouces oled le plus grand modèle
on pourrait avoir un double lecteur
carte sim on sait quel opérateur
français souffrent énormément
même si apple a marché international et
son fils un petit peu les opérateurs
français néanmoins c'est de retour en
force des double lecteur de carte sim
qu'on pourrait retrouver uniquement son
modèle le plus haut de gamme au niveau
des batteries sur les modèles avec des
écrans oled on dire alors des batteries
en l on annonce 25 % ont plus
d'autonomie des batteries qui pour
osciller entre 3300 millions terreur et
3400 milliampères heures quand l'été du
prix au niveau de l'iphone 10 5 2 8
pouces avec un écran oled
il y avoir des prix oscille entre 800 à
900 dollars c'est à dire à peu près 800
22 euros 924 euros ttc sur l'iphone 10
le grand modèle le disent + 6 5 5 pouces
oled honda contre 900 à 1000 dollars
soit à peu près 924 euros à 1027 euros
ttc et sur l'iphone le plus abordable
le site va bouillante pouces lcd en
avoir un tarif oscillant entre 600 à 700
dollars qui nous fera peu près 6 115 à
718 euros ttc ce cas m au final d'avoir
un iphone avec faith heidi un peu moins
cher et fit autant ou une rumeur a fait
état d'un écran oled sur ce modèle
d'entrée de gamme
ça me semble relativement compliquées
lorsque déjà pour les positionner sur le
marché pour une bonne compréhension au
niveau du consommateur
je crois relativement peu dites moi ce
que vous pensez de ces informations à
quoi voudriez que ressemble ce produit
vous marquez tous accusés quelques jours
je me sentirai une vidéo vous avez posé
ya quelques temps une question je
l'avais dit comment est ce que vous
voudriez sur cet iphone aqua voudrait
qu'ils ressemblent donc j'ai commencé un
petit peu agrégé tous ces résultats ont
fait cette vidéo on va faire un point
ensemble et ensuite on a tout envoyé
directement apple donc restez connectés
merci à vous d'être présent toujours
plus nombreux toujours plus nombreuses
marques qui manquent de vos questions et
des interrogations directement en bas on
retrouve quant à lui très très très
rapidement pour prochaine vidéo et
décide à porter vous vient ce message
vous embrasse ciao
[Musique]